we are heading down and I would just
like everybody to take a moment and pray
for me that I don't trip and fall in
this dress
Kaitlyn Bristowe may not have fallen but
her night at the 2018 Emmys was far from
picture-perfect the 33 year old
bachelorette star suffered a major
wardrobe snafu while attending TV's
biggest night on Monday shortly after
taking her seat Kaitlyn tweeted sitting
in the Emmys and my zipper just busted
and my butt is exposed and I can't get
up and I don't know what to do and she
shared this photo as proof on her
Instagram stories but it didn't end
there she followed up her first tweet
writing here's the kicker I'm in the
wrong seat and people are asking me to
move oh my goodness and while everyone
else that the award show was standing
and cheering for Betty White
Kaitlyn faced another dilemma thank you
I'm just gonna quit while I'm ahead
I either stood for Betty White and
showed my or stayed seated and looked
like an she tweeted luckily a few
audience members came to her rescue she
revealed quote the couple let me stay
and he offers me his jacket every time
we have to stand chivalry is not dead
but the drama continued according to
Kaitlyn's next tweet former bachelor
contestant Ashley Spivey offered up her
earrings as a makeshift safety pin to
hold her dress together then came this
tweet I've got tequila and we have asked
so many people how does no one have like
five pins and to make the story even
better Bristow revealed she ended up
having to move seats after all tweeting
they came and got us and moved us closer
to the front so I had to get up and
waddle down in front of everyone towards
the front with my hands clapping my
dress so quick quick wardrobe change
I'm not happy about it but I'm also not
mad about it either but all was well
after the show Bristow took tins two
stories to show off her new flapper
style after-party dress and then it was
off to the next event and now my date
and I will be headed to the Governor's
Ball which I feel like is way too fancy
for me
[Music]